russia's isvesta newspaper is reporting
that jailed opposition politician
alexia navalny has been moved to a sick
ward the kremlin critic was jailed
in february and has been on a hunger
strike since last wednesday
to protest the lack of medical care with
parliamentary elections less than six
months away authorities are cracking
down on kremlin critics
but they could be facing new threats
including from within the traditionally
loyal
loyal communist party dw's emily sherman
traveled to the southwestern city of
saratov where she met a local politician
who was determined not to be silenced
in the footsteps of lenin nikolai
bandarenka sees himself as a politician
of the people
just like his communist forefathers but
he
has a huge social media presence
bandarenka's youtube channel has over a
million subscribers
fight for your rights is the motto here
his social media accounts show him
fighting against corruption
and for more equality including as a
representative in the regional sarath of
parliament
and bandarenka doesn't shy away from
criticizing the kremlin
and the ruling united russia party
it's your actions the actions of the
russian government of your president
of your united russia party you gave our
national riches away to oligarchs
is facing what he says is a political
campaign against him
local politicians have accused him of
corruption for monetizing his social
media accounts
he could face a criminal case that could
prevent him from running in the upcoming
duma elections
the government is afraid of people
uniting uniting around a concrete
political program
which provides an alternative to the
course they have taken
throughout my whole career during the
many hours of live streams online or in
my videos
i never asked people to follow nikolai
bondarenko
i'm just asking people to be political
if you don't like what i say follow your
own line
the main thing is to not give up
in russia there are traces of the soviet
past everywhere
including in saratov the communist party
is still popular here and across the
country
even though critics say the party
ultimately follows the kremlin line
but even russia's so-called systemic
opposition parties have recently become
an outlet for people's anger at the
government
last year the arrest of a popular
governor from the right-wing liberal
democratic party led to weeks of
protests
in russia's far eastern city of
khabarovsk
every monday nikolai bandarenka has his
office hours
the 35 year old spends most of the day
with constituents
people stand in line for support with
issues from benefit applications
to problems with corruption
i've placed my hopes in bondarenko i
heard how he talks to people and i've
heard his speeches
in russia they don't like people who
tell the truth it's always been that way
so if he's trying to get the truth out
to people naturally he becomes
undesirable to the government you can
see how he acts at all his parliamentary
sessions he asks uncomfortable questions
the authorities don't like that
experts agree that the kremlin might try
to keep people like bandarenka
out of federal politics
ahead of the dumoul elections the
kremlin makes clear arrangements with
the main opposition parties about which
candidates can run and what results they
should get
they don't want to let anyone in who
will rock the boat
but despite attempts to intimidate him
pandarenka isn't
ready to give up
people today are hungry for justice and
for truth they don't trust the
authorities on the whole
i went into politics to prove to
citizens that lawmakers can work
honestly
nicolai bandarenka is already preparing
his campaign for the duma elections
and he hopes he will be allowed a fair
fight
you